so my husband and I are in baby step two
um I'm working to a full-time jobs he's
a school teacher and also has a training
like a personal training um gig on the
side that he does he rents his own
facility um but he's had it for four
years and my concern is that he really
hasn't made any profit off of the
business he makes just enough to just
pay the bills at in the business um at
what point do I have that conversation
that it may not be worth his time
um in the business just because it's
just not bringing
in anything that doesn't make money is
called a hobby it's not a side hustle he
likes work he likes personal training so
much he's willing to do it for free I
mean he makes some money but not as much
as I think he should because he's been
doing it for you're changing your tune
in the middle of the call which is it
how much does he really make net profit
on the thing so we can run range
anywhere from, 1500 to like 2500 a month